علي الغزاوي علي يسعد صباحك اهلا بك
نورتنا والف الف الف الف مبروك اهلا اهلا
فيك والله يبارك بعمرك يا رب وشكرا على
استضاف الموجوده معاكم
حدثنا اكثر عن هذه المشاركه وما الذي
اضافته يعني طبعا المشاركه اكثر من رائعه
ليش عشان كنت دائما بسال حالي بعد الوطن
العربي ايش بعد هيك ايش ممكن اسوي بعد هيك
فسبحان الله بتيجي كيف فرصه زي طوبشه في
العالم موسمها العشرين وكونها بموسمها
العشرين حبوا يعملوها على مستوى العالم
كامل وكثير فخور انا عم بمثل الوطن العربي
بمسابقه عالميه زي هيك مسابقه رائعه كانت
موجوده بلندن وباريس
وجودي مع شفات عالميين من فرنسا من
اسبانيا من المانيا من امريكا من مكسيك من
كل مكان بالعالم صراحه كثير رائعه طيب شيف
علي في كثير شيبس من العالم العربي اليوم
عم نشوفهم كمان ناشطين على السوشيال ميديا
مثلك هل هاي المنافسه حقيقيه بينهم ولا
شيف علي متميز انا احكي لك صراحه انا مش
كتير بطلع انه في ايدي منافس او في لي
ممكن حدا ينافسني ايش معين دايما بحب اركز
على حالي وش ممكن اكون احسن بكره وكيف
اطور من حالي وجودي طبعا بعد فوز بلقب توب
شات وعم بحاول اعمل بلنس عمل توازن بين
وجودي على السوشيال ميديا كشخص قريب من
الناس قريب من
المساهمين معك شركات بساندوني وبنفس الوقت
كشف يملك مطاعم وبطبخ بمطعم
عاصره تعكس الهويه الاردنيه
تقدم بطريقه مختلفه والبارحه فاز مطعمك
خبروني في قائمه افضل 50 مطعم حدثنا اكثر
طبعا المطعم اللي هو مطعم شرق او سطيف
معاصر الاشياء انا بحاول اسويه انه انا
بحب اركز واعكس ثقافتنا وحضتنا وتاريخنا
انا درست بجامعه سويسريه اشتغلت مطاعم
فرنسيه بايطاليه باسبانيا بالمانيا كتير
بلاد بالعالم بعد فوزي توب شيف حسيت عليه
مسؤوليه انه انا لازم اعكس ثقافتي وتراثي
احنا بتصور احنا العالم العربي بشكل عام
احنا عنينا من الاستعمار دائما كان حدا
بياخد من هويتنا حدا بخلان يسوي شيء احنا
ما بدنا اياه والطبخ 100% فحسيت مسؤولية
أنا لازم اعكس ثقافتي وحضارتي وتاريخي مش
بس
كالاردن كوطن عربي كشرق اوسط كامل عشانه
مطبخ مظلوم عالميا نوعا ما طيب شاف علي
انا بعرف انه انت متوجه لفكره الفاين
داينينغ والاطباق اللي فيها هيك زي خلطه
لكن اليوم الطبخ هو ثقافه وبمثل ثقافه بلد
دائما صار السائد انه لما نقول الاردن
العنوان منسف فيما يتعلق بالطبخ قديش شاف
علي بده يحاول مش انه يغير لانه هو جزء لا
يتجزء من تاريخ وثقافه الاردنيين بس انه
يضيف طبق يوازي فكره انه نربط الاردن مع
المنسف انا ضدها هي عباره عن منسف انا
بامن انه الاردن او سوريا او لبنان او او
الامارات هم مش محكومين بطبق معين هم
محكومين بمكونات احنا عندنا الارض عنا
مكوناتها احنا بنقدر نخلق الصحون او
الاطباق الوطنيه الجديده ما بتصور الاكل
قبل 100 سنه كان زي الاكل اليوم وما بتصور
الاكل بعد 100 سنه راح يكون زي ما هو
اليوم فاحنا دائما بنحاول نبتكر طعمات
جديده بس بنحافظ على هويتنا على طعماتنا
انه درست فن الطهي الاكاديميه الملكيه لفن
وسافرت الى اسبانيا واقل جامعات سويسريه
كيف بدا شغف عليه بالطبخ انا صراحه اول ما
بلشت يعني بلشت علاقتي مع الطاهيه لما كنت
في المدرسه كان عمري 17 سنه وكان دائما
يكون معاي سندويشات زاكيه بتعرف قبل
البريك بدك
تاكلوا اصحابي يحبوا ياكلوا سندوتشات اللي
معاي
انا بنعملهم مع بعض فكان دايما يحكوا لي
جوعانين طعمينا فمه هناك حكيت تعرف ما بدي
اعطيهم اياها ببلاش بدي ابلش اعملها
وابيعهم السندويشات اول يوم عشر سندويشات
اخر يوم بالمدرسه كنت عم بعمل من 120 ل
150 سندويشه من هناك اكتشفت
وعشان هيك تقريبا كنت كنت اروح على البيت
120 تقريبا ههه شكرا جزيلا شكرا